we'll go back to uh your company so
you're having these struggle sessions
you decided to define these definitions
uh what happened next
do you want to share anything
a breakthrough flew through the world
the happy philosopher over there um
well i can step in just to say again
that i want to again
dialogue i appreciate being here with
you guys because
having rich dialogue where there's no
victim villain narratives where you're
honestly seeking the truth because we're
on the same team the human team
i'd love to just point out in as we
describe this just again that i love
these people they're intelligent they
are caring they're living consistently
with their convictions and that's
exactly how i want people to live and so
the process for us went from when we
started when we had to push pause and
say hey okay you know in terms of gender
pronouns like
can't we find a way in which everybody
cannot have have to violate their
conscience and be able to be here
together and the guidelines in the way
in which we handle that would allow
everybody to show up and learn and take
advantage of that so
um so in terms of of when we did hit
pause and then entering into those
sessions i mean that we were trying to
define terms we were trying to
not just miss each other
same words different dictionary
defining words and then also we started
to define the process and we
look for tools so
one tool that's great which actually we
haven't had a chance to to properly
embrace you guys in the aloha spirit and
give you some some swag from our
organization but i tucked a book in
there that was really helpful for us
our board chair who actually does
professional conflict mediation um he
suggested a book called crucial
conversations and so defining uh
what is dialogue
how do we actually
have
conversations together where you can
be communicating the same definitions of
terms and
you can hear each other and
um and and actually it's kind of fun
because uh they use the term that what
you're doing in good dialogue is that
you're filling the pool
of uh
the common and understanding you want a
deep pool of being informed so you're
trying to make it a place where some
people aren't just being a fire hydrant
and just like overrunning the
conversation and then other people are
like shut off and not contributing to it
you want everybody to relax and be able
to contribute so that you've got a deep
shared pool of meaning um for you then
to make informed decisions around so so
that's where we were trying to go to was
just yeah we basically said we need to
do it we need to do this the com the
communication hasn't been healthy
because there are these narratives
forming that like we're these oppressive
people or somebody is oppressing and
causing harm
and there hasn't ever actually been a
concrete accusation of harm so that's
not psychologically safe because the
person who's being accused is like oh
how do i rectify it i don't know what i
did and you're there's nothing concrete
you know you're not telling me what i
did so how about what's happening how
can i apologize
yeah right besides everybody being laden
with the sense of like i'm sorry you're
feeling hurt and i don't even know what
i did like so that's something in terms
of defining psychological safety and
where not only the same definition of
the term but also processes where i love
it that you know just having a term like
a crucial conversation where emotions
run high where there's high stakes it
means something
it was very helpful for us to say hey we
want that to become the norm in our
culture like at the organization that
when when there is something that
matters you're not going to hide that
and have sidelined conversations with
other people um if it's you know
related to somebody then they get to
take part in that conversation
and then it also set up a process a
framework by which
you knew that if somebody approached you
and said that
i need to have a crucial conversation
there's you know that
i think in the chinese character for um
crisis is its danger and opportunity and
i think that applies in terms of these
crucial conversations where it's like
there's danger that something is at
issue here but there's an opportunity to
deal with it as opposed to
um what was happening was there was a
lot of
conflict that was never brought to the
surface and then that wasn't able to be
dealt with in a healthy way so
so those sessions were about us trying
to
adopt tools that will allow us to have
this conversation properly
and we did continue to dialogue things
you know people didn't leave
immediately we we got a chance to
actually
hear from everybody and fill that shared
pool and then what i think brings us
back to this conversation about critical
theory and whatever we want to call
what's going on right now um
that
is that people started to leave the
dialogue
and and that was the question in terms
of if it wasn't you wore them out they
couldn't handle it they weren't gaining
ground and they're like i'm out of here
to some degree but but it was i mean
yeah the experience that i had that was
just you know disappointing was that
in sticking to principles i until you
can point out something that we actually
concretely can change
um
then to me we haven't done the work
together um and there were so they never
said here's what i want you to do
no they did
no there were there were a lot of
different points where you know open
letters were written for instance with
demands in them
what were some of the demands um
just all the stuff that you're hearing
at all the companies like we need to we
need to be more aware of diversity maybe
we need some outside training we need to
be aware of other perspectives we need
to
um
we need you know certain kinds of
diversity on the governing board this
that and the other and so it's like all
of these things are great like we can
you know none of this is something we're
opposed to but it's the manner in which
you're approaching us that's completely
unprofessional and inappropriate that
you would you would go and like write
this letter and then like present it at
a board meeting like kind of
guerilla warfare style or something it's
just like this is not but so this is why
i i i think
you know it's clearly bad faith in in my
opinion from what i'm hearing especially
and it was an attempt to subvert and
steal power and so the tactics they use
are meant to maximize damage to you
while minimizing risk to themselves the
the the general idea is
they can cause you more harm by publicly
just slapping you in the face without
warning putting you on the spot where
you're forced to say oh
okay we'll do it whereas if they they go
to you in private or with an email then
you can easily push back with minimum
risk to yourself so they presenting you
an open letter at a meeting yeah common
tactics showing up with a protest i
don't i don't know if you guys
experience any like hard protest but one
of the things they'll do because then
these these corporations
are on the spot right now will you say
yes or no do it or don't and the
corporations panic and say okay you win
yeah exactly
because who wants to be the target of
the next you know big thing
in the media but you resisted you didn't
get into the demands
yeah i mean we had the advantages of
being the co-founders of the
organization and so having some
authority um instead of just maybe an
employee who's seeing all of this
happening and like i don't want to be
part of this but if i speak up i'll lose
my job
um
and also just being you know a scrappier
grassroots non-profit organization we're
not in the spotlight necessarily of you
know we have
a lot of work that we're doing around
the world but
i just think that we it was worth it to
us to really like lean into that
conversation and try to understand the
ideas and be really principled about our
our push back to those ideas
and we
while it was really draining
organizationally like we we spent a lot
of time on that process that could have
been going towards the work that we're
organized to do
um it was it was worth it to
to be able to in a principled way say
we're not going to do these things and
here's why that's that's another that's
essentially the tactic they know that
you know for a lot of companies
they might say how how much money is it
going to cost to do all these trainings
and keep having these meetings i was
going to cost 100 grand how much is
going to cost you just give them what
they want 10 20 just do it just hire
somebody just hire the diversity person
whatever right then we're done with this
right but that's a mistake short side
because then you're never done with it
and the long term effect is that now you
live under it yes yeah the appeasing
strategy doesn't work and for me it's
again i love these people and over a
number of years i i don't think even in
talking with them when we started to
identify some of the language and we've
asked them explicitly do you like it
seems like you might be adhering to some
of these philosophies is that the case
um they denied that i don't and i
honestly think it's the truth that they
they weren't aware of it there was
something that that they weren't taught
it was something that formally yeah yeah
and it's just something that was
influencing their thinking so my hope
too wasn't just to try to
you know hey i think that my intuitive
sense of this is correct and let's get
there as soon as possible it's like if
you want to treat people well and you
know be the change you want to see in
the world i want to have conversations
where you can actually look at the ideas
and at the end of the day the best ideas
will be the ones that influence your
policies as an organization so it wasn't
just to try to hold out and make it
annoying because you know
outlast them it was really my hope was
that people
would come to see that okay we can have
diversity but we need to unify around
what makes sense for the context of our
organization
and then also
again following the logic of you know in
terms of that one specific topic
can't there be a way in which somebody
doesn't have to compromise their
conscience and everybody can be in an
educational space together
interesting because you know it feels
like a
a chinese finger trip right that most
people's instinct would be to try and
pull their fingers out as hard as
possible and you guys seem to have like
leaned in and really made them explain
themselves and it got to a point where
they just couldn't effectively do it
that you know they talk about harm but
people are probably sitting around
saying i'm so sorry tell us about your
harm and then they can't i met with
every single one of them individually
for as much time as they wanted to take
because i genuinely cared i don't want
to harm people and i you know and and
yeah i'm sure that they had an
experience that's the thing in trauma
too that like it's not necessarily about
the experience but the meaning that you
make of it that it has an impact on you
so it's even if it's something where
it's like okay
there's no policy or anything that i can
necessarily fix or adjust i still just
wanted to hear them out because they it
was the experience they had was real and
i care about them but yes we did have um
you know the way that things went where
we stick stuck to the ideas um and then
over time too more came up so you know
when george floyd happened then that was
another big blow up moment of people
wanting to hashtag certain things and to
advocate and to do things that were just
out of the scope of what we considered
within our mission we don't make meaning
about individuals trauma and we don't
make meaning about societal trauma at
large
we show up and say hey we've got
rigorously
built tools to help people get through
things but we're not going to make
meaning about what you're getting
through that's just out of our lane
we're not therapists yeah and so anyways
there's some more you know just kind of
dissatisfaction around that we weren't
being more proactive about about that in
terms of either
advocating using our social media
or
in terms of doing that work internally
as an organization
and so
that was part of the story was was that
it at that point then people started to
and i think this is kind of you know
moving us forward in the conversation
at a certain point
people
were not interested in staying in the
dialogue they weren't interested in
looking at the best research that we
could find around how to actually you
know evaluate our policies and it got to
a point where people decided to step
away and what was unfortunate and i
think is also reflective of the
cultural moment we're in is that too
often it switches from the ideas that
you have being bad to you being bad and
and you know and i everybody's an
individual and um people when those that
did leave the organization all left in
their own you know way and experience
but we were called some names and it
wasn't our ideas that were ultimately
um
you know
the most uh
italicized um
comments so
it sounds like though you're just on the
other side of the culture now
you could you could choose to agree with
the woke people who are constantly
pressuring you
but it
sounds like you rejected it and now
you're having a conversation with those
who are rejecting you know critical
theory and and the weakness and all that
yeah i i mean in thinking about why that
twitter
thread that i posted ended up you know
going as widely as it did and and
bringing a bunch of attention to me was
that it was just i mean i i was sad
honestly it was like this should not be
rare you know but i i understand why it
is because the pressure is so great and
people don't want to see their their
organization you know sued ruined
whatever their reputation ruined and so
like you said they'll appease you know
like okay yeah let's do the training
it's no big deal let's just do the
training but what they don't realize and
like what to his point about um may the
best idea win sure let's engage in
dialogue let's talk about your idea
let's talk about my idea and may the
best idea when that that is gone because
there is no um there's no more of this
idea of of antithesis right which is how
philosophy was done forever like from
aquinas up until hegel was like hey i
have an idea i like this idea then the
next i come along is like no i have an
idea this is this is how we understand
knowledge this is how we have a unified
field of knowledge and he bumps that up
against the last guy's idea and they're
like okay this idea wins and on and on
and on until hegel where hegel says no
no we
this rationalistic philosophy project
has failed like we're never going to
find unified field of knowledge so now
the best way forward is to
take your thesis your antithesis and
combine them into a synthesis but what
he did in that is he didn't just change
he didn't just go from that dude's
philosophy to this dude's philosophy he
changed the whole rules of the game of
philosophy which was he established a
whole new kind of epistemology basically
saying well there isn't really an
objective field of knowledge that we can
ever find so let's just do the best that
we can to move things forward so it
wasn't like you know where you have an
idea and i have idea one of us is closer
to the truth you know we're gonna we're
gonna try to align with truth not just
like
move the ratchet forward you know um and
he so he changed that
understanding of epistemology also
changed the methodology by which we
arrive at the right solutions so it's no
longer like we're going to try our best
to align ourselves with what's
objectively real thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you